with animation i know that you don't  because i've done animation as well so  you don't get to actually see the  co-stars a lot of times  but how cool is it to work with dwayne  johnson like you all saw each other a  bit obviously so how cool is that  yeah it was wonderful i actually met him  after the recording was all finished we  met at a press junket  and i was finally able to like put the  voice  to the face and he's massive  and plays this amazing maui who's a  bigger than life character  so well he's kind he gives great hugs  he smells good my mom has a joke that  when  she first met him she went rock climbing  so there's also that  all around oh my god i love you  it was an experience great joke